hello chess fans we're here today with a
very special guest here to the st. Louis
chess club with the first time
international master album on you Mishra
Abbi
welcome to the club Thanks it's good to
have you here it's it's a pleasure to be
on this to have this interview awesome
well I know today is a big day here at
the club you've got a big sigh Mullane
anywhere from 15 to 30 players upstairs
have you played Simon
two or three signals did you lose any
games yeah like what place it like two
or three games it looks only two or
three no big deal no big deal
so I'll be the the big story with you
it's been in u.s. chess life it's been
all over the Internet you are the
youngest international master the world
has ever known
yes tell us about your chess life so far
how did you become an international
master well how it started so when I was
two and a half my dad introduced me to
chess
two-and-a-half yeah do you even remember
that your dad told me okay I don't
remember that far back but you started
teaching me chess and at age of five I
actually started going to tournaments
and then at the age of seven years into
my in six months I became the youngest
expert in yes and then at at the age of
nine years and six two months I became
the youngest master in US so I so
because of that there are only two
national records and I hope I explained
it I I say all right explained I have
them both and recently I also forgive me
I missed in charge - my strategy always
said well now so you took that title
from Prague and anga the formerly the
world's youngest international master
were you aiming to become the youngest
because I know you only beat the record
by like 15 days right yeah it seems
though isn't mix them so everyone else
in every way the kavita and everything
they said that it was in December - it
they they said they was like me mid we
hadn't totally December 24th but it
seems when you go and check every day
it's different we have one less we are
one less months you got to know that in
my last tournament so I didn't it was
like okay either you can't this
tournament or again there's one more
tournament but it was very difficult get
in there like did get to known in that
tournament so the driving force behind
how you started playing chess was your
dad yes is he a big big chess player
thirteen fourteen hundred oh okay I
should play him so what is weighted you
first
yeah I'm really intrigued by my kids who
play the game and who are real prodigies
from the start because you said you know
I don't remember two and a half I mean
who does but I know the stories I know
how it began
do you remember a certain point in your
life when it just kind of clicked and
you said I want to play chess or has it
just always been that way for you it
more or less has been always because
like after after I dad don't be chose
that you have to keep tweeting it's
difficult to not do for sure now you're
going to you're still rising of course I
mean no plateau in sight what are your
overall goals for chess the the
short-term girl goal is to become the
youngest Internet the youngest Grand
Master in the world and then after that
keep going and then later probably
become world champion so the youngest
Grandmaster ever is Sergey Karjakin
right yeah okay so how long do you have
like 22 months 22 months all right times
tickin can you make it yeah it was
likely how many GM norms do you have
they only played one tournament I think
I ABS your mom's serious oh well there's
still time because the thing is though
those are person go cage did you he just
Vista marginally yeah by a few days you
begin from I'm the gym at seven months
well who is that you said okay go cage
dear oh I can't say I'm familiar
okay so 22 months the clock is ticking
by the time you're watching this video
on YouTube he's probably a GM or at
least maybe two norms something like
that
so I want to dig in more into the non
chest questions okay I want to learn
about Abby the man what's your favorite
food pizza of course it's always pizza
has anyone ever said anything but pizza
that's why - it's great I mean just
something that comes to mind it's Keith
you're playing the fifteen to thirty
people as I said earlier tonight here at
the st. Louis chess club in a Simon
what's your preparation what are you
doing I did some opening and dad just
handles them like I'll just eliminate
days a week after like a few moves I'll
get to know like which ones are weak and
like which ones are actually like
fifteen sixteen hundred so just
eliminate the weak one sit then I'll
just move on just like a final two three
people it goes and then oh they don't
finish it off eliminate the weak ones
I'll tell you what that phrase makes me
think of this image we're using for our
poster upstairs here at the club tell me
the story behind this photo right here
you look like a killer in this poster
what where was this taken
I think this was taken in very
international one of the I'm not like
one of those super supposed to sell
fluid I feel like in a normed I think
that's them no that's a different right
okay this is probably taken very
international I'm not exactly sure
is that your face for all of your games
is that what the players are gonna be
looking at tonight not really no because
like it's one of the scariest spaces in
the game I'll tell you what you keep
staring at me mm-hmm put the pressure on
so this so your dad I saw you outside in
the hall he was he was going over all
your accolades this stuff I didn't even
know about and I was reading up on you
before this interview so there's got to
be a lot of pressure there how do you
handle the pressure to play the game
into excel at it I just go played like
okay what's the worst that can happen
you just lose you lose you can come back
later right yeah yeah what's a good
philosophy they have some people I asked
that question because some people
crumble under pressure some people Excel
and thrive under pressure and it seems
like you're in that latter group okay so
no doubt you're traveling all around
yeah you're trying to get these Grand
Master norms taking it to the next level
how can people get involved in helping
Abhi's succeed I have a go fund me page
please donate to help she'll help me
become young as pretty master in the
world so let's say you become the
youngest Grand Master in the world I
mean at some point I mean you're
expecting to be a chess professional
right yeah robbed it gonna be going to
Vegas you're gonna be going to the
you're gonna be going all the way the
candidates right winning everything
are you humble yes all right well there
we go he's humble
so what do you think your records gonna
be tonight at the Simon mmm 20 look
whatever we like let's say 20 people
show up 20 join me 20 out of 20 yeah
okay 20 months it's good attitude to
have
[Music]
what was your what were your thoughts on
this norm Invitational it was a very
good place like the arbiters and
everyone is very friendly just what was
it might come er might come of course
might come get to go to Forest Park or
anything here in st. Louis all chess
that's not that's so many so many other
strong players they come here and say oh
there's so much to see and do but yeah I
mean it's all business
I mean there were no rest days right
yeah yeah there's nothing so in there
this is one game a day you have time but
yeah it was like - each two groups two
games two games like one like one at
five o'clock in the first day then two
games - looking that - he had to be here
because a full session until 4:00 and
then players me until 5:00 not like like
please me it was basically a she's
explaining the rules the way it was
written you know it looked like wait
four to five you had to read them
right but it was just fourth clock some
like two three minutes huge winged
wolves and then that was over so Abby
what's next for you where you going
after you leave st. Louis I'll be going
to Charlotte in December
oh the chess Center sure that Justin
yeah oh cool
yeah I have yet to be there but I need
to really check it out I know Peter and
his crew of a really awesome place over
there is it a Norman tour just know that
know that very cool so it's just Bam Bam
Bam Bam back to back right yeah we have
like a few we have like maybe a month
not exactly a month but yeah we have few
days is there anything else is there
anything else you want to mention to the
people watching at home about you your
chess career hopes and dreams anything
also the kiss barrage his foundation has
helped me a lot so every three months
Alexander Chanin come Centrify say for
the like a week he comes in he comes in
he gives me three puzzles and problems
so he's your coach yeah cool
and every six months Kasparov takes our
like a valuation it sound like he got he
shall we annotate some games to me
because I may show it on the screen and
basically he tells it he basically young
he tells us like where problems are and
stuff is that the young stars young
stars thank you yeah very cool that's
that's cool yeah I mean you can't get
much better than kiss para right yeah
what what's he like in person what do
you think he's very nice he's intense
though right yeah doesn't fool around
yeah
hey you don't fool around either though
you speak your mind right yeah very cool
hobby I guess right now what I can say
first of all to everybody out there
remember to donate to the GoFundMe if
you can find the time one of the
outstanding up-and-coming stars in the
chess world quite potentially maybe
maybe in the future of the youngest GM
of all time but if not still a force to
be reckoned with Bobby thank you for
joining me here tonight and good luck
tonight in a society it's a pleasure to
be here
ABB's thank you thank you
[Music]